♪ (music) ♪
Give me one minute and I'll show you
how Cloud Armor could help protect
your applications and websites
against [null] of service and web attacks.
Cloud Armor is an enterprise-grade
DDoS defense service
and web application firewall
that leverages Google's vast expertise
in protecting key internet properties
to provide built-in defense against
L3 and L4 DDoS attacks.
Cloud Armor also allows you
to mitigate OWASP's top ten risks
by providing pre-defined rules
to help you defend against its hacks,
such as cross site scripting
and SQL injection attacks.
Cloud Armor has IP-based
and Geo-based access controls
so you can allow or deny traffic
based on the source
and geo-location,
or filter your incoming traffic
based on IPv4 and IPv6 addresses or CIDRs.
Setting up Cloud Armor
is very straightforward.
You'll find Cloud Armor
in the Google Cloud Console
under the Networking/Network
Security section.
There, you can create a security policy
and configure it to help you protect
your web application.
The Standard pricing model is simple.
It's a pay-as-you-go measuring
and charging
for the security policies and rules
within that policy.
Or you can choose
the Managed Protection Plus,
a value-added service that starts
with Standards here,
then adds Adaptive Protection,
access to Google's DDoS response team,
DDoS bill protection,
and other protection capabilities
in a predictable subscription
pricing model.
So next time you're looking to protect
your web applications,
take a minute to look at Cloud Armor.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/armor.
♪ (music) ♪